hi i'm maria today i'm inviting some
friends over for dinner but i have a
secret instead of creating something
from scratch i'm preparing a delicious
blue apron meal of pan-seared scallops
and caper butter with red rice and fresh
orange salsa let's see if they can tell
the difference
hi guys it's riya welcome to my kitchen
i'm so excited to have you here i'm so
glad i don't have to cook
well today i'm having a guards night and
i'm cooking for you guys scallop and
some veggies so i'm gonna start with
rice cause it takes a little bit longer
time
and speaking of not having to cook
tonight
how difficult to put dinner every night
for your families oh my goodness it's
really hard especially after working a
long day i don't who wants to go home
and cook yeah i have five kids and they
are the pickiest eaters i feel like i'm
making a menu for each of them
my son he is almost two years old and he
is wild pikas eater
and we have some veggie tonight
i think cauliflower is kind of mild
flavor
so i think kids would like it and also
papers are colorful it's super simple
and i'm gonna just put in the oven yeah
oh it's gonna taste so good
now i'm making orange salsa and i want
to make it a little bit fancy because
it's a girl's night so i got black
orange those are amazing yeah i love it
i have this belju it is a fermented
grape juice
so all of us are mopped well it's the
biggest challenge for dinner time for me
it's that hour between when i pick them
up from school and when we get home and
they're starving and i've been working
all day and i don't have time to make
the meals and they're just going nuts
and that's when they get boxed mac and
cheese that's right it's because it's
too real
so while i'm chatting with you guys my
salsa is already done so i'm going to
move on to the style of our meal
beautiful scallops oh my goodness yeah
so scallop seems like very
intimidating to cook at home but it's
one of the easiest ingredients and looks
so fancy
yeah i think it's a great also like date
night kids can go to bed early exactly
kelly both of you and your husband are
chefs
so you guys make gourmet dinner every
night no no those days have sailed um
once we had kids we got realistic and
you know we start making convenient
meals
so when you cook at home how long does
it take to cook dinner for you guys 20
to 30 minutes that's like that's long
enough especially like the shopping and
making sure that you have everything you
need my struggle is like what to make
for dinner yeah like it's like looking
website and it takes so much time they
smell so good oh great yeah
right
i think the you know pro tip i guess
it's um when you put something in a pan
you kind of want to start things up but
scallop or stick just like be patient
don't move it at all it's beautiful yeah
so i'm done everything is
i'm very surprised actually how quick it
was so last step i'm gonna assemble this
is the veggies i
roasted earlier and this is like
mom
tip i'm adding veggies in a rice bar so
i don't need to
wash another bowl
and i'm adding cream fresh
i've never thought to add creme fraiche
to something like this i never would
have thought to make anything like this
at home much better than just making
spaghetti
and more vegetables yeah
so i'm going to plate it and let's eat
together
beautiful right
and it smells amazing
i love how it turned out it's so
colorful and it looks so delicious so
let's dig in
first i got scallop this is
incredible i love it so much there's so
many textures and flavors so i have one
big surprise for you so this is from
blue apron no way oh my god
seriously yeah wow
yeah so i cook everything in front of
you but everything is pre-portioned and
delivered to me so you don't need to go
grocery store you have 50 plus options
every week
and you can just get to pick and the
best part for me is i don't need to
think about meal plan like i just pick
what i want and it's delivered to my
door one less thing to worry about
honestly at the end of the day
and you get this restaurant quality meal
who's hosting next meal yep
i don't do these sheets yeah right my
friends and i need a lot of flexibility
when it comes to cooking for our
families
luckily blue apron has tons of delicious
and time-saving recipes that add fun
flavor and variety to your dinners
[Music]